well we've got more clouds in the sky
this morning i don't know if it's nice
to feel the humidity that's come back
it's kind of a reunion with the monsoon
moisture out there a little early light
some color in the sky and we're
definitely going to feel more humid as
we get through the day so we are looking
for maybe a slight chance of some
thunderstorms there we go kind of
getting through the numbers there we're
on a different picture lots of 80s
around the valley this morning we also
have humidity that's in the 50s as far
as dew points that's telling us there's
a little juice out there to work with
and as we get through the day and get
that daytime heating that is going to
cook up some possible thunderstorms
around especially over the mountains
70's in indian springs in mesquite this
morning still some 80's around boulder
city 70's over in kingman the good news
is there is a trade-off it looks like
the smoke is retreating as i roll the
smoke forecast
caldor fire 217 000 acres but there's
more containment of it sorry we're
missing a little bit of data here on the
smoke forecast that's the black that you
see there but we will be looking for
less smoke this is tropical storm olaf
remember acapulco getting that
earthquake overnight uh about 24 hours
ago
they're being kind of brushed up there
along the coast now from the waves and
the wind from tropical storm olaf and
now tropical depression mindy bringing
rain across the southeast with hurricane
larry out in the atlantic i mean this is
the time of year when hurricane season
is really ramped up we've got smoke
we've got heat we've got wind across the
west and heat warnings that will stay in
place for us through tonight at nine
o'clock for the same areas except the
mountains where we'll look for a better
chance of thunderstorms today about a 30
chance in the mountains and a very
slight chance for the valley now
it's not huge but we could get some
lightning some outflow winds from storms
around 105 today drier breezy winds on
friday and then for the weekend 104 103
still going to stay hot but drier